- I can totally see
why in the '50s,
this was in '60s,
actually some psychedelics
were already legal
in a medical setting against
depression, whatever.
But back then depression
was not a big thing.
So I was like,
I was very sure actually
people would work on it now
because this was so powerful.
And then actually for two
years I was looking around,
are there any companies
I can invest in?
There weren't, and
then I did it myself.
(relaxed music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and we're
mixing it up a bit today.
We're gonna shift from
politics, hallelujah.
We're gonna be talking about
crypto, about longevity,
and of course about
magic mushrooms.
Joining me is the founder
of Apeiron Investment Group,
a board member of the Hayek
Institute, and the founder
of the Angermayer Policy
and Innovation Forum,
Christian Angermayer.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Hi, Dave.
Pleasure to be here.
- It's good to be with you.
You were one of like 10 people
that I would occasionally
check in with
in the last year and a half
to make some sense of the world
and talk about
COVID and lockdowns
and science and fact
and all that stuff.
So I'm gonna just
start you broadly here.
Where are we at in
the world right now?
Where are we?
- Well, (indistinct)
to hear I'm vaccinated.
So I'm pro vaccination.
It seems still to be a
big debate in the US.
Always when I post something,
I get a lot of hate
and love and whatever.
But generally, we
discussed it before,
like if we take it
one level higher,
one of my ideas or my fuses
that sort of the whole world
is kind of going into,
or is already in a
mental health crisis.
Meaning it's really the
mental health crisis
in terms of really like
what we at the moment
define as mental health crisis,
like depression, anxiety,
addictions, opiod addiction.
All of these numbers
are skyrocketing.
But I think we have
way more issues.
We as a sort of
planet or humanity
is going through mentally,
which we have not defined
yet as a real disease.
So if you talk to so many
people, they feel literally,
they can't even express it
because there is no word for it.
But some I think,
the majority of people feels
that the world is
going in a direction
which A, doesn't
make sense for them.
So they can't understand
a lot of things anymore.
And B, they subconsciously
and that's even worse,
know there might be no
place for them in the world,
let's say we the tech
elite is building.
So I'm always, when I
have these literally,
every time I, whenever
we do a new investment
and I'm telling my friends,
we just did a investment
in a brain-computer
interface company.
And so my vision is, and
I'm super excited about it.
That in 10 years, 15 years,
all of us are gonna
have brain implants,
brain-computer implants.
And then we can
sort of do things
like from telepathy
to communicating
without any device.
The sky's the limit,
what you can do
with our brain is directly
linked to the computer.
I think it's fascinating.
And always when I talk
to friends of mine,
I realize how deeply
terrifying that is for them.
And it's just one example.
So what I'm thinking is
that I'm coming back,
why I'm saying that
in terms of COVID,
so I'm thinking,
again, the world,
it makes less and
less sense for people.
At the same time,
they don't feel sort of at home
or they see they
don't have a place,
and that frightens them.
And fear unfortunately
brings out the worst in us.
So and fear and trauma
is also one of the
underlying root cases
for mental health issues.
So I think we all have this
collective mental health issue,
again, for a disease we
don't have a name for yet.
It could be like,
I don't have one,
it's not a good, short name.
But like being
afraid of the future
or don't feel at home
in the world anymore.
So the outcome is though that
we become extremely tribal
because we try to find
refuge or like a home
or like stability in a world
of permanent unstability.
And it's not gonna change.
The world in 15 years, or 10
years will be so different.
We never, ever,
we haven't had a change which
was happening so quickly.
So we resort in this tribalism,
which practically
makes also every,
now coming back to COVID,
every rational
discussion obsolete.
Meaning we completely
lost the ability I think
to be in the middle
of something.
It's always like from here,
we had all these discussions.
Like both sides.
In America, the Republicans,
or the right wing,
the left wing.
It's insane, and I think there
is a more underlying reason
which is the one
I just described.
- Yeah, so that's why I
wanted to have you on.
Because I've been talking about
it on the show for a while
that it seems like we're
at the end of one world,
and there's a new
world on the horizon,
but people are worried about it.
We know about all the
mental health stuff,
but you were kind of
in the psychedelic game
before all of this
was happening.
You've been thinking about
how do we make people happier
and less depressed
and with less anxiety
and all that stuff
for quite some time.
When did you get
interested in that?
- I got interested, I
can tell you exactly,
in 2014 when I had my first
own magic mushroom trip,
which was in a country
where it's legal.
Which was-
- Which country was that?
- I always have to
say the disclaimer.
- Was that Holland?
Where was that?
Which country was
that? That was Holland?
- No, it was actually
on a really tiny island.
It's called Canouan
in the Caribbean.
So it's legal or not
classified in most countries
in the Caribbean, Latin America,
and actually in the Netherlands.
That's the interesting part.
And by the way,
because I maybe, I
come to this in a point
that I think psychedelics
should be taken
in a medical context, or
at least with a guide.
So I had a very good
shaman doing it with me.
But just for the ones who
are watching now and saying,
"Jesus, he's a druggie."
I always was extremely
comfortable to talk about it
because I am the least
druggie person you ever,
I have never drank alcohol
ever in my whole life.
I have never smoked a
cigarette, never smoked a joint.
Actually, never
did anything else.
I drank coffee when I was
28 for the first time.
- Oh, Christian, not coffee.
- Coffee's okay now.
But what I wanna say,
So I came very virgin
to that whole thing,
and then it was hands down
the single most meaningful
and important and life
enriching thing I've ever done
in my whole life, full stop.
Nothing really comes close.
And I have to say I was
already a very happy person.
So and immediately
after that, I was like,
okay, if it can do this
to me, a happy person,
I can totally see
why in the '50s,
this was in the '60s, actually,
some psychedelics were already
legal in a medical setting
against depression, whatever.
But back then depression
was not a big thing.
So I was like, it must be that,
I was very sure actually
people would work on it now
because this was so powerful.
And then actually for two
years I was looking around,
are there any companies
I can invest in?
There weren't, and
then I did it myself.
- Right, so what's that
like when you're like,
"All right, I'm gonna be
the magic mushroom guy."
And I should tell you,
I've done magic
mushrooms many times,
and it's been a while, but
I've always loved doing it.
I never had a bad effect.
I wasn't depressed
after or anything.
If anything, it's exactly
what you're saying.
It sort of elevates
the good stuff.
But sorta what I think is
interesting about you also
is that you're basically,
but I don't wanna put
words in your mouth,
you're basically
politically a conservative.
And I think it's kind of,
there's this dichotomy
between, wait a minute,
he's a conservative, but also
he's the magic mushroom guy.
I sort of say
that's what the new
sort of conservative thing is.
So can you talk a
little bit about that,
and then how you
went ahead and said,
okay, we're gonna make
this into a business.
- All right. So first of all,
totally fine, conservative.
I actually would
say I'm rationale.
And this is like,
I think one of the big
problems is already
that I think we
still using terms
which don't fit in
our time anymore.
There should be no left and
right, because left and right,
I always tell my friends
who are like in Germany
and the Social
Democrats are like,
I tell my friends you should
have come home in the '80s
because you won.
100 years back, there were real
issue for the working class.
So then somewhere, you
reached everything.
You should have reinvented
yourself, funnily,
but that's another topic.
I find actually there would
be a place for real social,
in a positive, and a
socialist in English
always have this negative.
We call it Social Democrats
like center socialist
because I think never ever
than in the last 60 years
than today, the working class
has a real issue because
their jobs are gonna vanish,
all of them, 100%.
So if I were a
left-wing politician,
I would take that as my thing.
How can I help the
real working class?
How can I, how can we create,
and this comes back to my worry
about the mental health state.
We have to create a world
where we all have a place.
Because let me take one analogy,
which is not a nice one,
but to sort of paint
a negative picture
because we had all of that.
So I love history, and if you,
I searched for like a time
which is sort of
similar to ours.
I know history never
repeats, but rhymes like,
so but if you go in the
time, 1850 to 1910, 1915,
there are so many parallels.
The elites were
completely tech savvy.
You had Jules Verne the author.
He was writing actually
about going to the moon,
about flying to the stars,
about going under the sea,
People forget that
it was the time
of the World's Fair in Paris.
Actually this was the Eiffel
Tower was built as a symbol
of technological innovation.
So there was the biggest
elevator in the Eiffel Tower.
You had all these amazing books
writing about actually
future like fantasy,
but it became real.
Anyway, so you had
this enormous optimism.
You had Berlin by the way being
an incredibly liberal city,
like gay rights, like party,
like the elite was in
a collective happiness.
But 95% of the people
were most likely thinking,
you're fucking crazy, because
they were all farmers.
And what it actually
was, it was the dawn.
So we were moving from
an agrarian culture,
agrarian society, into
the Industrial Age.
This was the evening,
or the eve sorry,
the eve of the Industrial Age.
So but unfortunately,
in that Industrial Age,
a lot of the people
who were needed
in the agrarian
age were redundant.
So again, like the
same like today,
the poor people had no
place in that future.
So what did the people do?
They invented kind
of nationalism,
and they invented communism.
Because that was the tribes
they were resorting to,
to actually sort of get
a little bit of a healing
from their anxiety
and their fear.
And that actually gave
the world two world wars.
So my fear is that if
we're not finding a way
to take 100% of
humanity with us,
us I mean like the
tech elite who says,
"Hey, we're gonna go to Mars,"
And I do think we're
gonna go to Mars.
But if we don't take
all the people with us,
it's gonna end very badly,
because I can say it again.
Fear brings out
the worst in that.
And that comes then back
to psychedelics, because-
- Wait, let's pause
for one second.
Then we'll get into
the psychedelics part,
'cause I love this.
So are you shocked
how the tech elite
seem to hate the regular person?
Like if you asked
the regular person,
what do you think the head
of Twitter or Facebook
or all of these people
think about you?
They think, oh, they
wanna censor us.
They don't want us
to speak freely.
They wanna own our data
and all of that stuff.
So you're trying to
basically rectify that.
- Well, so you think
that the ordinary people
hate the tech people
or the other way around?
- I think it's a
little bit of both,
but I consider myself more
of the regular person.
I think the average person
thinks that the big tech people
just basically think
that they're fodder
for whatever their
algorithms want,
and however they can make money.
Something like that.
- Well, one other theory,
and I'm copying that
what I'm saying now,
'cause so far an
original thought,
but one of the things, what
(indistinct) sort of coined
was this idea that if,
again, if humanity,
I don't wanna say goes bad,
because I still don't know,
I have not reached a conclusion
if it's good or bad or neutral,
but it could be hindsight.
Like in 100, 200 years,
we might look at
this time and say,
we have split up in two species,
because you have a part
of the humanity who says,
"Hey, bring it on."
Let's fly to Mars.
And by the way, one
very simple fact.
If you wanna go to Mars,
we're gonna need
to change our body
because our body is not made
for not even Mars travel,
not to talk about space travel.
You die of cancer
within some weeks.
So if we wanna go to Mars,
it's not just going to Mars.
We're gonna have to modify, and
nobody's talking about that,
But I think everybody knows it.
- Right, so that's the whole
transhumanism movement,
basically.
- And by the way,
and it's gonna happen
because we already have it.
You have a heart,
if you have a stent,
I think it's got
an image like that.
So it is already a me
technological intervention.
So at somewhere where
you're comfortable.
And we're gonna get more
and more and more in it.
but there might be a part
of the humanity who says,
"This is not for me."
I don't wanna merge
with machines.
And again, this sounds
already so sci-fi.
But it's gonna gradually happen.
So humanity might
split into species,
and in 50 years, 100 years,
we're gonna look back
and say, well, that.
And that's already like
sort of in a mini way
happening now because you
have this one part of humanity
who wants to sort of go wider,
further, the sky's the limit.
Like let's bring it on.
and then you have,
again what I said,
the other part who
maybe doesn't really,
I don't wanna say intellectually
because this sounds degrading,
but let's take a
positive example.
And I really mean it positive,
and sorry by the way, I'm
not an English speakers.
- You're doing all right.
- Not a politically
correctness things,
because I always can say
I didn't mean it that way.
So now take a bus driver.
So he or she maybe
can't explain you
how autonomous driving works.
But somehow I think humans
always have a very
good gut feeling.
So as a collective, we're
actually pretty smart.
And some of the bus driver knows
this is not going in
the right direction.
I'm not gonna be a bus
driver in 10 years.
And that again makes him
maybe resent the people.
So again, it comes back.
we need to sort of take
him or her or whatever
on this sort of thing.
- So now link that to
psychedelics for me.
- So first of all,
I don't have an answer
on that, like fully.
Because I just think like,
I think the bigger
fear that I have
is that we don't even
discuss the problem.
We discuss so many
bullshit stuff.
Can I say bullshit?
- You can say bullshit.
- So I think this is your point.
This is the point of a
lot of friends we have,
that a lot of discussions,
if you see the real issue
or the real problems,
a lot of discussions
are really absurd
because like, (indistinct).
But again, I see
driving through the lens
that I'm looking at here,
I understand why the
people have this discussion
take all the identity politics.
It is again another
form of tribalism,
how in the 1850s and following,
the people invented communism
so to say, and nationalism.
Now we're inventing
other crazy stuff.
But it makes us feel at home.
It makes us feel us
against the rest of it.
So how do psychedelics
come into it?
So where do I start?
Now, because it's like,
so one thing why I'm always
very, a little bit hesitating,
not hesitating like,
so it's very hard
and I have to describe a
psychedelic trip first.
- Yeah, I was gonna
ask you, please.
And in a certain
way, it's extremely,
let's call it spiritual.
You could also say
religious, you could say,
so the thing is,
it's very mystical.
And practically every word,
our language is not made to,
it's really out of worldly.
You sort of leave the
realm of something
and go to another one.
So what I wanna say is the
language is not so easy.
This is why by the
way most religions
are based on
psychedelics, provenly,
including Christianity.
And this is why they
all use these pictures
and describe things
like the burning chair,
or chariot which goes
in the air, whatever.
Because they can't put
actually their experience
really in words,
because there are no words to
describe a psychedelic trip.
That's first.
So and if I do it, then I
need to use religious terms.
And the problem is
that religious terms,
in our world especially,
are incredibly loaded.
So if I use the word soul,
then you might think, or
might think about, than I do.
And another person,
either God, whatever.
So I try to stay as neutral
and try for the viewers
to make a little bit
of an abstraction,
and don't think necessarily
in the narrow terms
of any religion, but
in a wider meaning.
So when you do psychedelics,
you have a part in your brain
which constitutes your ego.
And this part is, depending
which psychedelic you take,
is either really reduced to zero
or at least heavily
regulated down.
So it's called default
mode mechanism.
So practically in this
part of the brain,
there is something which
tells you you are Dave
and this is Christian.
We have a different history.
You have all the
happiness you received,
you have all the
pains, all the scars,
everything which makes
Dave Dave is there.
And that goes down again,
very downward or to zero.
And interesting in the same
moment you're doing that,
something else is emerging.
Or at least it's heard.
Maybe it's always
there philosophically,
but you realize it, again,
hear it, see it, feel it.
And now we can call it a soul.
We can call it in a voice.
We can call that your
subconsciousness (indistinct).
It must don't necessarily,
I'm not saying it proves by
the way that God is there.
That's another discussion.
But that is definitely
100% of the people have.
And this sort of soul
and a sort of universal feeling
gives you a lot of insights.
So if I try a little bit
to make the main ones,
the first one is,
which is probably super
important I think for everybody,
is it shows you who you really
are and what you really want.
So it might sound,
it's a simple question,
but most people
either don't know,
or they know they are afraid
of accepting it in any form.
It can be simple stuff.
I had people who
took psychedelics
who were extremely wealthy,
and realized the
only thing I want
is to spend more
time with my family.
But I didn't dare to say it
because I'm running this big
corporation or whatsoever.
Anyway, so it
sounds, by the way,
everything I tell you
about psychedelics
sometimes sounds super simple
because you could read it
in every Deepak Chopra book.
But you perceive it on a level
that it's an absolute truth.
You come out of
it and like, okay,
I realize now what I want,
and I'm gonna change my life
in a way that I'm happy.
So that is one big part,
is that sort of realization
of your true self,
also the negatives,
also the painful ones.
So it's incredibly trauma
healing, which is by the way,
and I have to say more often,
a trip must not be nice.
It's not a party trip.
It's nothing you
wanna do in a disco.
So it can be extremely
cathartic, it's
really cleansing.
But you're always gonna
feel better after.
And I actually had, very
colloquially, we say bad trips,
but I like the word
more challenging trips.
But they were actually the
nicest or the best ones.
Not the nice ones
but the best ones,
because they gave me so much.
Because I learned so much
about, again, fears, whatever,
which we should try
to hide somewhere.
And you dissolve them.
Anyway, so that's one thing.
And the second big
thing, what also happens,
is you feel connected to
nature and other humans
in a way you can't describe.
And one other form,
so there are several sources
of mental health issues,
if I'm being oversimplified.
The one I already said
is fear and trauma.
And the other one
is lost connections.
A lot of people feel
disconnected from everything.
From the world, from
people, whatever.
And psychedelics bring back
their enormous sort of love
for the creation, for what
it's like for humans, animals.
This is why by the way,
this is why a lot of
people go vegan after that,
or at least say,
"I wanna be more responsible
towards my environment."
And then the third part
is very interesting.
And that is maybe, and all
of these things are very,
I think, helping in what I said
to detraumatize the world.
The third one is
in the weeks after,
in a very simplified way,
your brain is literally
growing a bit.
We call that neuroplasticity.
So which helps you on the
one side to develop habits
or to get rid of habits.
So it's extremely helpful if
you wanna get off an addiction,
stuff like that.
But also if you look
at brains after,
the people seem to
be more creative.
And also more, again, it's
more open for the world.
And I think what we all have
to have to go into this time
with the same mental
health, is like this awe.
Like this sort of the
future's gonna be fine.
We just need to
find our way back.
So but if you tell
that a 60-year-old,
even leave away
whatever the job is,
so unfortunately if
you look at the brain,
when people always think
of the aging of the body,
but our brain, roundabout when
you 30, is starting to age.
Not just in a sort
of mental capacity
that you're losing
gradually a little bit.
But also you're
literally closing down.
Like if you go in an
old people's home,
why do people not make friends?
You would say they have time.
They have the whole day.
They should make
a lot of friends.
You literally can't.
Your brain is not wired anymore.
So you make your friends in
your 20s when you're open.
So I for example, all
my friends I have,
but I actually, I make
new friends all the time
because I think I'm always
on a lot of psychedelics.
So psychedelics,
(muffled speaking).
- We became friends
in the last two years.
Now, I don't know if you were
tripping at the time, but.
- But honestly, so you get
back this sort of openness
for the world.
And so these three things,
if I look at what we need,
A, we need to have the
discussion that we,
let's say the elite are we,
we need to offer a world
where these people,
I said like the sort of the
lower level jobs (indistinct),
where we find new jobs for them.
But at the same time,
we need to make sure
that they want it by the way.
So and again, telling
a 60-year-old,
look, you know what?
You go back to university.
Even if he intellectually can,
it doesn't have that
impetus anymore at 60.
However, he could have it
maybe with psychedelics.
- Right, it's like telling a
journalist to learn to code.
I guess that's a big problem.
- You could maybe if you
get a little bit of help.
And by the way,
one maybe example,
it becomes not too
esoteric where the UK,
as the first country, I
think the first country,
recognized loneliness
as a disease,
and especially in old people.
And it's literally by the way,
if you look at the
health data of people
who are lonely at any age,
their health is
dramatically getting worse
because we're pack animals.
So if we are alone,
our stress level
goes up permanently.
So we get depressive,
which is again,
depression has an impact
on our immune system.
So there is really
a downward spiral.
So they're not saying yet that
depression should be true,
sorry, that loneliness should
be treated with psychedelics.
But the first step is always
to speak it out and say,
okay, loneliness is a disease.
Because now we can start
going to the regulators
and saying, hey,
maybe we can prove you
in a proper clinical study
that psychedelics
also might heal,
not just depression, what
we're about to prove,
but also loneliness
and stuff like that.
And I think, again, coming
back to the beginning,
there will be some
when a disease, again,
we need a cool name
for it or a cool,
but which is a
fear of the future.
And again, then once
we have named it,
we can maybe run clinical trials
and we can bring
the ball in motion.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm
so with you on this,
that I think you're right.
People have this sort
of existential dread
about the future.
It feels like the past
is kind of broken,
and they're just like,
oh, they can't even see
what is in the future.
So for people that know
nothing about this,
I think they're probably going,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
Does this guy just want me
to be tripping on
mushrooms all day?
So what does an actual
way of life look like
incorporating some
of this stuff?
Are people just
microdosing all day long?
- So microdosing is a,
okay, Let's leave the micro
'cause it's a complex answer.
Let's stay with
what we are doing.
So I have a company,
it's just IPO'd,
which is called ATAI, A-T-A-I.
And we have more than 10
new mental health drugs,
most of them psychedelic,
in development.
So what we're doing,
we're taking actually,
we have a lot of what we
call anecdotal evidence.
So I'm always careful
because I know
that I had this amazing,
not just one trip,
and I know many friends,
but in a scientific view,
this is anecdotal.
It's like (muffled speaking).
At the same time,
I know to be fair,
there are thousands of
reports and (mumbles).
So and some of these
drugs actually,
interestingly, in
the last millennia,
in the last century,
were legal, again,
or medically available for
depression and stuff like that.
But it's sort of old data.
But what we are doing,
we're taking these anecdotal
and partly historic,
so to say evidence,
and really doing,
and this is important,
very rigorous,
really state-of-the-art
clinical trials
on the FDA and
European supervision,
in order to really prove it.
At the moment I have to say,
look, I do think magic
mushrooms potentially,
or ketamine, or ibogaine,
or all the psychedelics,
DMT, (indistinct) DMT.
So I have to potentially say,
because it's in a sort of
scientific way not proven.
But we're proving it
now, once and for all.
And we are actually, with some
of them already in phase two,
which is sort of pretty
advanced for biotech.
Some are at a little
bit earlier stage.
But sort of I would say within
the next five, six years,
hopefully some of our
drugs will be approved.
So and then this is important,
they're gonna be
medically available.
Not for take-it-home,
not on prescription,
but that you go to your
psychotherapist or your doctor,
and you do the trip
with him or her.
Which is important
because you need a guide.
Actually, when you look where
these drugs are coming from,
they were used since
thousands of years
in ritualistic,
shamanistic, religious way.
So you always had a priest or
a shaman with the disciple.
And kind of can say
the psychotherapist
of the shamans of our time.
But it's important.
So we wanna have it in is
kind of restricted access.
Not because, I think ultimately,
big parts of humanity
will sort of benefit from it.
But it's a very powerful drug.
So it's not that you,
it's not like an aspirin,
you pop it and you're fine.
Again, part of the process
is really touching your
deepest fears, all of that.
So you have to do it
with a psychotherapist.
But that's what we
wanna make available.
And I think we're
in a good way of it.
- This may sound like
an amateur question,
but is everything that
you're testing right now,
is it all actually
natural substances,
or is any of it made in a lab?
- Not all of it.
So some of the substances
we have in our portfolio
at that time are originally
nature substances.
But in any case, may they
be natural originally,
or some of them
are like take MDMA,
which is a synthetic
drug from the beginning.
There's no nature, natural MDMA.
So both.
But in any case,
we are just using
the synthetic version
because you need to be
precise in quality in dosage.
So you can't,
you will not have
homegrown magic mushrooms
in a hospital with a doctor,
because you need it
exactly for a patient.
You want clean and
perfect (indistinct).
- Can you just tell people
how people actually
get magic mushrooms?
'Cause I remember
when I was in college
and my buddy came in and he had,
well, he bag of magic mushrooms,
and he's like, we're
gonna do these,
and blah, blah, blah.
And then I was like, "Well,
where'd they come from?"
And then he told me and I
actually couldn't believe it.
And it's still sort of amazing.
- Well, at the
moment, first of all,
for all of the viewers,
in most countries,
any form of psychedelics
are illegal.
Which is actually sad
because they weren't in the
'50s and '60s for good reason.
But anyway, it is what it is.
We're gonna hopefully make
them medically available.
But at the moment I
have to say, yeah,
this is not a medical advice.
And I think I made
it clear, even I did.
So just saying.
But if somebody
says at the moment
he or she uses magic mushrooms,
that means they've
grown it themselves.
Like it is a mushroom.
So and in the Netherlands,
you can grow it and
eat it yourself.
- But in essence,
it's just a mushroom
that's growing off
cow poop, right?
- Yeah, well, you
can grow it at home.
I grow it at home in a small,
I would say like-
- Like a greenhouse
or something.
- But yes, in nature, they
actually often, not always,
but often found on cow poop.
So not always, but that's
one of their favorite places.
And then by the way,
they grow in those countries.
So this is what also,
like if you go back,
actually most religions
are based on
psychedelic consumption.
- Well, that's why
I was asking you.
Because not to be funny
about it growing on cow poop,
but it's metaphysically amazing
that this mushroom
that grows on cow poop
basically can cause you
to have a five-hour trip
that could potentially
change your life.
And when you laid out
those three steps before,
I've done it enough in my life
to know that everything
you said there was true.
- Do you mean it's benefit,
interesting that it's
growing on cow (indistinct).
Just thinking about it,
it's an interesting-
- It's just a little bizarre.
- But I was just thinking,
because the question is when
exactly people are seeing it.
So I make it, I have to phrase
it a little bit vaguely,
but we're gonna do a very
big university project
with a friend of mine
who by the way you
should have on the show
if you haven't, like
Brian Maresco who wrote,
who worked years,
because so many people
would say instinctively,
you should take psychedelics.
This is what Moses took,
Jesus took, Mohammad took.
And now I have a
fatwa. No, I'm joking.
- You're not the first.
You're not the first time
they show, don't worry.
- Well, actually,
you say Shia, right?
So the Iranian side of Islamic,
she's endorsing psychedelics
as something which
brings you closer to God.
And actually, interestingly,
also a lot of the Orthodox Jews.
And it's very interesting how
that merges with religion.
So coming back, so
because my friend went out
and really researched temples
and grave yards and whatever,
and try to find out,
literally proving me
what did people eat.
What do they have
in their stomach?
What is the residual in
a mystical cup, whatever.
And this is how he could
trace back most religions,
provenly, that they were
all doing psychedelics,
including early Christianity.
And we actually have very
interesting conversations
with the Catholic Church,
because they're saying
kind of inofficially,
like if this was the
reason, which by the way,
I deeply believe
this was the reason,
one obscure niche
cult from the east
became the dominating
religion in 300 years.
Meaning this was always,
I'm brought up Catholic.
I was always thinking
like how did that happen?
Because people were killed,
this is not a fun
religion to be in.
And then my priest always said,
"Well, they were
so big believers."
I was like, that's a
big belief to get killed
and slaughtered, whatever.
But if you think about it,
if they used psychedelics
which take away
the fear of death,
because you know that there is,
at least you think you know.
Again, religious discussion
for another thing.
Like there is an
afterlife, whatever,
it gives a completely
different framework
sort of to operate in.
Anyway, so but now actually,
the Catholic Church
has come back and say,
if that is proven to be the case
that early Christians
took psychedelics,
we might use it again
because that seems to lift
spirituality up a lot.
And it does.
And I think there
are already sects,
like Santo Daime in
Brazil is a Catholic sect.
Then they use psychedelics.
And I think we need that
spirituality back in our world.
So I'm a very, my
view is of religion
is like whatever you believe,
it's definitely healthy for you.
- Would you say
there's any specific,
would you say there's
any specific risks
related to all of this?
- To psychedelics
or to religion?
- We're kicking the religion
conversation for the next time.
For psychedelics.
- Well, I have to say, both
legally but also responsibly,
we are about to prove
sort of both the efficacy
and the risk.
This is why clinical
trials are made.
So there have been
though great studies
over the last 50
years, repeatedly,
which show that psychedelics
have a very, very
low risk profile.
So what I would recommend,
if the people watching now
sitting in front of a computer,
google, it's my
favorite chart of all.
Google David Nutt chart.
David and Nutt, N-U-T-T.
David is a very
famous neuroscientist,
and very famous for his
research around psychedelics.
And so he wrote a book
which shows how wrongly society
looks at drugs in any form.
Actually, a lot of
people would say today,
it's still like, "Oh
my God, psychedelics."
And then at the same time,
they drink a glass of
wine which is pure toxic.
So the essence of his
book is this one chart
where he rates all the
legal and illegal drugs,
from alcohol to cocaine
to psychedelics,
how risky they are
and how bad they are
for our body and our mind.
And then maybe I'm spilling
now about the secret,
but if you look at the
chart, you see on the left,
you see alcohol as
the most risky drug.
Actually before heroin.
And then at the very right,
practically mini, mini, mini
risk, you see psychedelics.
So and then it's
very scientific.
But again, we are
trying, or not trying,
we are about to prove that now
in a very proper
clinical FDA setting.
- All right, well, we're
gonna link to that chart below
so they can see it while
they're listening to you.
What else are you
interested in right now?
I mentioned
longevity at the top.
That seems to be a big one
with all the tech
people right now.
Can we actually live longer?
- Well, for sure.
I mean, that's not
even a question.
We're gonna live longer
because it's already happening.
Our life expectancy is
sort of is going up.
But I think like if I come back
to the optimistic
view on the future,
I think we're going, it is
amazingly interesting time.
We all don't know
where it leads us,
but I think if we
instill back curiosity
and all for the
wonder of the world,
and not just the
5%, not just the 1%,
but like the majority of
people, that's one step.
And then I think
once you have that,
so once you have it in general,
let's call it neutrally
curious outlook in the future.
And at the same time,
if you're happy,
and I have this one luck in life
which actually is a
different backstory
than most people
have psychedelics,
because a lot come
to psychedelics
because they search healing.
This is why I
didn't wanna do it.
I was like, I was
always a happy child,
since I can remember.
I have a bad day,
but in generally,
I liked myself as I've said.
I'm a very happy person.
And I've also always said
I think I'm not dumb.
So hence, already
when I was 12, 13,
I was like, okay, this is
kind of a great situation.
Don't mess it up by putting
any drugs into your brain.
Don't touch alcohol,
don't do it,
because you just can get worse.
So when I was in, once you're
happy and once you healthy,
and once you curious
about the future,
you wanna sort of
experience that.
And I wanna stay here.
So now as long as I want,
so I don't think we're
gonna live forever,
because forever is
a very long term.
I do see the realistic
chance that even you and I,
because we're not 15
anymore or 10 or 20.
We are like the middle.
It's actually an interesting,
so I think like the sort of
group in the middle is 40 to 60.
I think the younger
people are, I mean,
if I talk to my
ten-year-old godson,
then he's gonna be some
hundred years for sure.
I'm very sure that we're
gonna push life expectancy
into some hundred years
in the next 30, 40 years.
By the way, very important.
Because a lot of
people then think,
"Oh my God, I'm gonna be 100."
Like they see people who
are 100 now, like so.
No, there is no way to
push life expectancy
into some hundred years
without rejuvenating.
So it's good for your
(muffled speaking).
So we're gonna be young again,
even when it happens,
and we're gonna live
significantly longer.
And I think our mind is
not made for eternity.
So even if we potentially
could live very, very long,
my expectation is that
we will come to a point
where every one of us,
and this point might be
completely different.
Some people might say,
"Hey, I had enough."
I had enough Christmases,
I had enough birthdays,
I wanna go now on my own terms.
But I think that's the
ultimate because ultimately,
I'm not even concerned.
And I'm kind of libertarian.
I wanna mind my own business,
and I want everybody else
to mind their own business.
And I also wanna wanna
decide my own time of death
so to say, when I had enough.
When I'm not interested
in the world anymore.
I do hope that
with psychedelics,
that's gonna come very late,
and I'm gonna enjoy
that for a long time.
But longevity, so
long story short,
and we have several companies.
The two big ones are
Cambrian and Rejuveron,
where we sort of really try
to do cutting-edge struct
development, like four things
which sort of make us really
live significantly longer.
And it's gonna work out.
In 10 years, you're
gonna see, again,
coming over the (indistinct),
the next 10 years,
earlier than people think,
gonna be so world-changing
in many ways.
we just need to
look forward to it.
- Yeah, give me one more thing
that's really on your
mind at the moment.
You wanna go crypto
or you wanna go somewhere else,
as we get to the future
that's not depressing.
'Cause that's what I
want my audience to see.
That it's not depressing.
I know it's sorta, it's
painful at the moment,
but it's not depressing.
- Maybe one thing.
you're the first one
I'm talking about
because I'm
formulating it myself.
So maybe it's not, I
try to get it across.
So it's about,
so we're living in these
money-printing spree.
And I think, one idea I have
is like most people would say
because it's traditional
economics tells you
that it's not gonna end well.
And we have all the,
with all the sort of,
or all the consequences,
like if you're talking
about an asset price bubble,
or at least asset
price inflation, maybe
a real inflation,
maybe the wealth gaps,
so there is a lot of things
which are associated
with money printing.
So it could be though that
it's the most important thing
we can do at the
moment, for one reason.
If I look at the world,
what we haven't talked about yet
is sort of the competition
of economic and
political systems.
So practically you have
three relevant players.
Forgive me, Russia.
It's Europe, it's the
US and it's China.
And it's actually with some,
obviously US and China
is a very big difference.
Europe and the Us is
a little bit less,
but all three are different.
And I think what
politicians were used to
is that in the old world
of economic linear growth,
in the '50s, in the '60s, '70s,
whenever a country
was falling behind,
Think about Germany, by the way.
In around 2000s, we were
called the sick man of Europe.
And then the Germany
economy took up again.
So in the old days,
countries could underperform
relatively to other
countries for a while.
And then they got
their shit together
and then sort of they caught up.
Because it was possible
to catch up in a world
of linear growth.
So we now, and by the
way, I have this theory
of a very, very high-level
communist party member.
So this was like, okay, they
really thought about it,
which is scary.
Is that in a world of
exponential growth,
think about tech companies.
So we are already
with tech in a world
of exponential growth.
And look at Google,
look at Facebook.
Once you have enough,
I think in English
we call it velocity,
are number one, and
you're gonna stay,
look at Apple, and you
dominate the market.
So exponential growth is
actually fostering monopolies.
So in the same, what
we see on companies,
and I'm coming back
to money printing,
we see I think on
nations or regions
that we are living in a world
where if one nation for some
years is practically ahead,
it might be that some
when they can never be,
they will always be number one.
So if China is the first one
to really develop AI properly,
if China will be the first
one to get a quantum computer,
if China is gonna first
want to really be ahead
10 years in space tech,
so there are
certain innovations.
If you are ahead, you're gonna
cement your number one status
and game over, at least
for a very long time.
So why I'm saying that,
what happens in a bubble?
I don't even know,
I don't wanna say
if we have a bubble
on the stock market.
What I wanna say is
we definitely have,
I think we all agree with that,
We have a time of
intense money printing,
of monetary inflation
as a preservation.
So you can make fun of it now,
that sort of money is
pressured into the system.
And like young people, whatever,
trade on Robinhood,
up and down the line.
But the truth is even if you
take GameStop out or whatever,
I don't wanna make an
argument (indistinct),
a part of that money
is going in innovation,
and actually a lot.
So at the moment,
thanks to the bubble,
a lot of innovation is financed.
So if you think what
money printing does,
it takes away
practically capital
from the ones who are savers,
who are savers are
actually, forgive me,
but the older people.
And they took a lot out
of the world already.
And you give it to
the younger people.
So the younger people
might make stupid stuff.
But overall, they actually
finance smart stuff.
Look at what is working
in the stock market.
Climate tech, because they
care about climate tech.
Everything they care about,
all these story
stocks is working.
And yes, there might
be some stupid ones,
but the money is flowing
into a lot of good stuff,
which actually, if we're lucky,
cements the technological
leadership of the US.
Because I say it that
way and go like it,
I'd rather trust
a 16-year-old kid
to make buy allocation
decision than the government.
So the government
tries to do innovation,
which never really works.
I'd rather want to have a lot
of money pressed the system
and a lot of investors,
retail and institutional,
push that money into innovation,
because I think we
have to succeed.
Because one thing,
and I don't wanna say
anything against China
with a lot of discussion,
but I like to live
in the Western world.
And actually, many,
I think Europe,
I think the world with
all the sort of bad stuff,
what you can say,
about the West,
it's actually the place
where most people wanna live.
And so I want the
West to succeed,
but if you look
again into history,
always the dominating
economic superpower
became also the dominating
political power.
But also, setting the
agenda (muffled speaking).
So I desperately want America
to sort of succeed in that.
And I think money printing
might be the smartest
way to do it.
So I would just go on
printing just because we need,
we can't lose in a time
of exponential growth.
We can't lose out on innovation.
- Right, it's so crazy.
So just keep printing the money,
which oddly devalues
it at some level.
But at the same time
allows young people
to just keep pumping it into
all the cool new things.
And then hopefully
that's in that way.
- But there will be good
companies at the end.
And again, the price is paid
by all the people
who have savings.
But I don't wanna say any,
I don't know how to
say nice in English,
but if you're like 80,
you're not gonna matter
in 50 years, most likely.
I'm very optimistic
on longevity.
- Despite all the
longevity stuff.
- Despite all the longevity.
So it's kind of like,
I like to see this
money printing
as kind of almost the
5000% inheritance tax.
Because you take it
away from the people
who are gonna leave this planet
in the next 20, 30 years,
and you give it to the younger
people in their future.
And that's what we all want.
By the way, again, that's
where we could merge
left and right.
Like climate change
is a problem.
The question is just do we
change it by, I don't know,
standing on the street,
or do we change it
with technology,
with real innovation, with
going to renewable energy,
but making that even
way more efficient,
getting fusion finally running.
I have a very cool
investment there.
And it will work out
the next 10 years.
If you get fusion running,
forget about solar.
And the thing is fusion.
So but tech will save
the world, not kill it.
We just need to embrace it.
- Tech will save the
world, not kill it.
Well, I love that you're
positive for the future
and that you wanna
bring everyone with you.
Because you usually don't
really hear the tech people
talking about that.
And I should say that I know
that you're a wise investor
because you also did
invest in locals,
which I hope makes
you more money
than your mushrooms and
longevity and everything else.
That is my hope for you.
- By the way, I think
because I was an only child,
so I always learned I need
to be nice to other people
to have friends to play with.
And no success, I mean, at
least this is my view on it.
You don't wanna have success
without friends succeeding,
and on a bigger picture,
you don't wanna go,
one of my big
worries is actually,
and I know they're watching,
but my parents are
a good example.
Because I discuss a
lot, like they're 70.
I'm like, okay, I need
to really hurry up.
But they don't even
want all that stuff.
That's one of
these good examples
where I have all
these discussions.
If I had certain things,
and some things are
available readily,
they don't wanna use,
because they're like,
no, this is natural.
I'm like, no people told us
since thousands of years,
this is natural that we age.
It's just a story
we told ourselves
because we couldn't prevent it.
Anyway, I want to take
the people with me
because I think that's, I mean,
that's maybe the
psychedelic ride,
maybe one last sentence.
I have one cliche,
it's very, very cheesy,
but I think it actually
summarizes happiness very well.
So I was thinking like what
makes people happy overall?
And by happy, I don't mean that
giggly, like in the moment.
but really like this content,
exactly, zen wise, et cetera.
So I think you
need three things.
You need any form of faith.
I touched it already a bit.
And by the way, coming
again back to why,
because it's fear and trauma,
and the biggest fear we
all have and we don't admit
is that either we die, you
could die or I could die,
but even worst is actually
that other people
you love could die.
So I'm permanently terrified
that some when my
parents will die.
And everybody is terrified.
The children could happen,
something to children,
to your partner,
to your parents, whatever.
So and this is like
a permanently trauma
or permanently nagging fear,
and religion, again,
I don't wanna argue
if it's real or not,
but if you believe in something
which is a little
more than this world,
it takes a little bit away
this sort of nagging fear
of losing people for good.
So then the second thing you
need is you need purpose.
So people want to
know why they're here.
They want to be needed.
They wanna be included.
And the third is love.
It's very cheesy, but
we are pack animals.
We need family, but we also
need love in a wider circle.
We need a good environment,
friendship, whatever.
So unfortunately, coming back
on the whole development,
all these three things
in the world we live in
are actually dissolved a bit.
So faith is on a record decline.
Purpose kind of as well,
because I told you,
most people feel
that their job might not be
there anymore in 10 years.
And also love in a certain way.
I don't wanna make the
pitch because as you know,
and I'm telling myself,
because we're dissolving
in record speed,
sort of things which
give us in a certain way,
how is it in English?
Whole, like give us,
like family systems,
but also communities.
It's not just
about who you love.
It's about the community.
When I grew up, there was like
a school club for everything.
So any of these three things
which make our actually
mind happy is on decline.
And the good thing
is if they come back,
psychedelics gives
you back of that.
They give you back
faith, spirituality.
They give you back purpose
because they show you,
hey, this is what
you really want.
Even if you're 60,
whatever, you can do that.
And they give you back most
important love and connection
to close people and the world.
So I think that's the formula
everybody should wait
for without psychedelics.
I think it's just a very good
tool for that to hold on to.
- Christian, where
can I send people
to find out more about you?
I feel like a lot of
people that are gonna,
we just really scratched
the surface on all this.
- We just do another, another.
I love to talk.
I'm admitting that I love
talking about this stuff,
so we can do another
one or whatever.
- But where can
I send people to?
You have a newsletter.
Is there a way to, where
can they sign up for that?
- No, it's just
for close friends
because I'm very
political correct.
Sent, you mean like website,
or what do you mean send to.
- If they wanna find
out more about you
and what you're doing.
- Well, on the website
of my family offices,
Apeiron, A-P-E-I-R-O-N.
And then what is called
minus, investments.com.
Or go on ATAI.
This is really
worth checking out.
So ATAI is the
psychedelic company,
it's definitely the coolest
company I've built so far.
I hopefully have 100 years
to come and build some more.
But like, stock
market listed now.
So there's a lot of
information out there.
Actually Twitter.
I sort of hate and love Twitter.
- It's a love and hate thing.
- Although I think
it's very exciting.
People need more love.
It's just like I don't know why
people are so hostile there.
So LinkedIn is a
little more friendly.
- I should have realized
that I'm on a very
special newsletter.
That's not the
public newsletter.
Now I'm even more honored.
- A very small group
of people, friends.
- Christian, I really love this.
I would love to trip
with you sometime.
We're gonna have to do that.
So I hope to see you soon.
- We're gonna go
to the Caribbean.
I'm a great shaman.
- Oh, do you act
as a shaman too?
I don't know if I wanna
go here on a public,
we're gonna set it up somewhere.
- We'll figure out something.
All right, It was
great seeing you.
- Yeah, but I think I
have compassion a bit,
and this is a good starting
point for tripping together.
- Nice. All right, sounds good.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about tech
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our tech playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlists.
They're right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.